what are some i i have some other gaming
channels that i think
yeah i got some gaming channels as well
uh i know that you watch
dark main as well i think dark man's
really funny yeah really good comedic
delivery like
jokes he's literally the definition of
jokes that aren't funny but when you
deliver them well they're just so
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah yeah he's so funny and uh i met him
once i don't think he remembers because
very briefly but he was super he was the
exact same as his videos
yeah um he does me he blew up with lee
content but he does general gaming stuff
as well
yeah just a really odd guy yeah just
really funny is he exactly like he is in
his videos when i met him he seemed like
that
okay so he's always endearing yeah he
does like
a very like what's that like dry
delivery of like unfunny jokes sometimes
funny jokes yeah but
either way it's always funny and i met
him in real life and uh
he was wearing like he was dressed up as
thanos
he had like purple because he's popular
right right he had like a glove on
and i met him and he for some reason he
just like completely unrelated was like
i'm thanos
and i was like oh i see that sick
okay and i was like all right because i
met his friend
uh red riot as well he's really funny
dude really nice guy uh
makes great content um i think also oh
yeah one of my
favorite uh gaming content creators is
corey gaming
about the fighting game yeah about the
final game some of the best
analytical content on youtube in my
opinion because
his his content is all about fighting
games but he breaks it down in a way
that's so
general that anyone that one makes you
[ __ ] interested in finding games even
though i have
zero interest in fighting games you know
what i mean i have zero interest
zero knowledge about finding games i
come out of a corey gaming video i'm
like
yeah you know you are the type of dude
who sees like a how-to tutorial and like
how to start fishing god's like buying a
rod on amazon
like that is so gone gets in got like
you watch the
the alphago documentary right and like
the next week
after go on watch this documentary about
girls like i want to buy a go board
let's play go no because because i i
like my one niche is watching videos i
have zero interest in
i like that but like watching like
watching of watching a content creator
basically be able to break it down in a
way that makes me interested in it that
is true that is that is my niche and
interesting and that is that is what i
want to do with like anime to like with
my own content yeah and that's like the
content creator i respect so like with
corey gaming
he like breaks down fighting games on
like i think like a social level he goes
into like the psychology
of why of why people act the way they do
in fighting games like
like some i i honestly i think like
every video he's done is a banger when
it's like an
analysis video okay but he literally
like breaks down the psychology
of what goes into like the fighting game
community why salt
in the fighting game community is like
such a big thing and
it's and he also has like some really
interesting stories
in between all of this analysis and it's
just it's just like the complete package
it's everything you want in an
analytical video but just it's just
fighting games but you have to
you can have zero interesting fighting
games and you can appreciate what he
does because
a lot of his analysis can be applied to
pretty much
just life in general like he he like
there's a lot of like
he ends a lot of his videos with like a
with like a nice little message you know
what i mean
um which can be applied to a lot of
things like something you can take away
yeah yeah exactly to watch more of his
stuff because i
i don't think i'm subbed but yeah i'm
gonna check him out um i think another
a few of the gaming channels i like uh
obviously little kerbs
who does the barrier speed runs yeah the
best [ __ ] post of all time because
obviously donkey which we all like
yeah everyone loves the guy who does
did like the whole joke in his mario
maker video if you guys don't know
donkey
i mean you should know dunk he's like
the biggest gaming channel yeah uh he
did a video where he like
made his own level and got the world
record on it and was like bragging about
it yeah
and then obviously dunkey makes certain
excuses in his videos when he can't beat
a mario maker level like oh you know my
little brother was playing i was playing
with the usb steering wheel
yeah so this this youtube creator little
curves you also is just a god
at mario like an absolute god who gets
like the world record on everything
like i think he's won like every
nintendo speed run competition yeah
on mario maker right he did a video
where you obviously
did donkey's course blindfolded with a
steering wheel it's so
[ __ ] good like i love that level of
[ __ ] it was it was such an amazing [ __ ]
post but
there's also like a second layer of
enjoyment actually seeing him do it like
he's actually insane he's an actual
[ __ ] guy
it's it's [ __ ] posting has gotten to the
point where you need to be like
the [ __ ] posting itself is just your
pure skill yeah you know what i mean
it's insane it's so good and also other
gaming creators that i like i don't know
if you've seen nitro rad he just just
like
i know that i have 30 minutes like
essays on gaming
and it's just like it's like that warm
feeling of like watching youtube in 2014
right closed up you know watching
someone talk about video games
really like just just passionate like
yeah i don't think
i think uh there's nothing that's like
oh my god he's hilarious or like there's
nothing that's like
mega like whoa super unique just all
around just just a great package
right he's super such a nice guy and
just seems really into it and really
loves his gaming
uh stuff that's always the best yeah
yeah one one gaming youtuber i like uh
like i kind of respect for a different
reason
is a relaxation um just because like i i
got into him because he did this like
amazing analytical video on persona 5.
and like i respect him because his
editing is [ __ ]
next level yeah and it's like it's so
bittersweet watching a dude who is like
relatively not that big on the youtube
sphere who can just
[ __ ] crank out like just these
incredibly well edited videos right i
mean like
the whole reason why like you know our
editor mood on like the reason why i got
into his stuff is because
that dude's editing on his videos
[ __ ] next level right and it's just
like i know i respect him as a youtuber
and as someone who
edits like videos and i'm just like if
anything i've gotten a lot of like
good editing ideas like creative ideas
from his videos being like oh [ __ ] i
never thought to
do something like that oh that's pretty
cool i thought i have to do something he
got a bit of drama
yeah he did didn't he and i think he was
like i mean i i i don't know what was
you know right and wrong but yeah i
think that he was uploading a lot of
videos about it to his channel and i was
like dude i don't think you should
upload this many videos yeah
yeah do you think you played like two
videos and space for a week about it i
was like no
don't do this man like just double down
dude we've established just go
down i do want to also mention that um
if we did recommend any youtubers that
turn out to have done some [ __ ] up
stuff
uh yeah we don't know that we're just
recommending based on purely content
yeah we're separating the creators from
the creation as much as possible and
also we don't follow
everything going on i mean a lot of
these dudes i we just watch
and like the content we don't keep up
with what they do in their personal life
whatever they do that's on them but
like yeah i'm sure i'm sure one of these
creators you mentioned is going to be
like they
they they murdered somebody yeah they
touched a kid
exactly right because obviously when you
know pewdiepie recommended youtubers he
got
[ __ ] for that yeah right i mean but yeah
i want to make that known that yeah
any creators that we recommend please
don't wish hundreds for it yeah
also finally one i have one last gaming
creator that i i want to recommend
uh so i've been watching this guy for
like forever
he's called like kadiras and he did like
his whole thing way back was that he
used to do just ps1 game reviews
right and it was kind of sad because i
felt like he'd stagnated for a long time
just doing ps1 ps2 games and it was kind
of like all right nice and he wasn't
really growing much
and then i'd say like last year he
really turned it around and started
doing some really damn good
videos like insane amounts of effort
like hour-long videos about like
skateboarding games
and he's just really upped it and like
the amount of edits in this dude's
videos are insane
yeah uh and just he's broadening out a
lot more and he's making some really
good [ __ ] right now so if you like
gaming content
and also he's british and it feels
sometimes like his jokes are like
british kids tv show
yeah and it's like it's weird because
like you can sound so
very stupid and very like i don't know
very crackheady
uh and it feels very childish at times
right but it's just it's good and you
know
if you're a 12 year old you can enjoy it
and yeah yeah 24 year old like i am you
can still enjoy it and it's a bit silly
but
are we talking like poo poo pee pee
levels sometimes yeah
it's just nice like you said earlier
it's nice seeing a creator just step it
up and like
really like i just want to give credit
where credit's due and uh it's
especially nice to see a creator step up
when they haven't made some update
like videos just level up yeah it's hard
right when you're a creator when you're
stagnating i've been there
yeah it's really hard to just be like
you know what [ __ ] it i'm gonna i'm
gonna put all this effort in i'm gonna
take a risk it might not work
try something new and it'll work you
know most of the time it doesn't work
out but you have to keep it up you have
to keep taking those risks
awards yep and it's nice seeing because
i can relate
someone who's stuck in doing [ __ ]
black butt left for like two years
because i can really relate to getting
out of it
and i really want to give credit what
credits do yeah because i think i feel
like there is a space for update videos
but
at the end of the day the audience like
but for the most part don't really give
a [ __ ] you know what i mean no if you're
going to drop something big then just
drop something big
if you're not then you like what you can
convey
in an update video can be conveyed
within your next project
unless it's gonna be like i'm gonna be
away for like a [ __ ] month or two you
know what i mean and that's just
at this point that's just like calling
in sick for you for your best you know
what i mean
all right gang i'm not gonna be
uploading for a month just uh calling in
sick yeah